con decenas de millones de vacunas
contra el cob y 19 de astrazéneca ya
distribuidas sorprendió un anuncio
explosivo de un alto funcionario de la
agencia europea del medicamento ema el
doctor marco k velar y jefe de anti en
preciosos y vacunas de la ema dijo el
periódico italiano il messaggero cada
vez es más difícil afirmar que no existe
una relación causa-efecto entre las
vacunas de astrazéneca y los rarísimos
casos de coágulos sanguíneos asociados a
un bajo nivel de plaquetas los
comentarios llegaron cuando la
universidad de oxford suspendió sus
propios ensayos en niños en medio de
nuevas preocupaciones sobre la vacuna
aunque la de más en proceso de emitir
una declaración oficial la noticia de
que el problema aparece sobre todo en
los jóvenes ha suscitado la preocupación
de muchos países que ahora utilizan la
vacuna en marzo más de una docena de
países entre ellos francia y alemania-
suspendieron el uso de la inyección de
oxford astrazéneca por el problema de
los trombos pero la mayoría de las
naciones de la unión europea ha reunido
su uso a mediados de marzo después de
que la ema dijera que los beneficios
superaban los riesgos el martes el
primer ministro de reino unido
johnson abordó el tema en una planta de
fabricación del suero así lo mejor que
debería hacer la gente es mirar lo que
dice la mra4 regulador independiente por
eso lo tenemos y su consejo a la gente
es que sigan saliendo que se vacune que
se vacunen por segunda vez sea genial
pero el regulador británico es una de
las muchas agencias que siguen
investigando los problemas de coágulos
de sangre en eeuu la administración de
alimentos y medicamentos no ha dado luz
verde a la espera de su propio estudio y
la organización mundial de la salud
también está estudiando los problemas de
coagulación si se confirman los riesgos
parecen ser bajos hasta ahora con un
estudio alemán que encontró 31 casos de
coágulos de sangre y 9 muertes entre 27
millones de personas vacunadas